Before we get started, let's take
a look at a concept that will be
very useful in our examples
of variable capture.
Actually, the fancy name for
this is capture of lexical environment.
Feel free to drop this in
any casual conversation if
you really want to look like a nerd.
An alias is a simple way
of calling something or
someone that has a complex or
funny name.
For example, say you're a huge,
professional wrestler and
you want your name to scare
the crap out of your opponent.
Do you seriously think
Terry Gene Bollea will do?
Of course not.
That's why he goes by his type alias,
Hulk Hogan.
Or you're just starting your
career as a pop singer, but
your parents bestowed upon you
the aristocratic sounding name of
Florian Cloud de Bounevialle Armstrong.
It certainly sounds impressive, but
your fans will have a hard
time remembering it.
Better go by the tape alias, Dido.
In Swift, you can also give
new names to existing types.
And this is extremely useful when
the original name is complex.
Something like being able
to call Kurt Douglas.
Much better, don't you think so?
Let's see a few examples.